تحقق إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA) في مكالمة وثيقة للغاية
بين طائرتين ركاب في
مطار جون كنيدي في نيويورك ، ألق نظرة
هنا على هذا الفيديو الرادار لحادث
طائرة دلتا هناك باتجاه الجزء السفلي
من الشاشة كانت تقلع إلى
جمهورية الدومينيكان عندما كانت
شركة الخطوط الجوية الأمريكية  عبرت الطائرة باتجاه الأعلى
إلى المدرج ، ولحسن الحظ ، اكتشف
مراقب الحركة الجوية ما كان
يحدث وأجبر طائرة دلتا على
إحباط الإقلاع ،
وألغيت
دلتا 1943 تصريح الإقلاع ،
لذا فهي خطة إلغاء إقلاع عام 1943
ترفض
whoa وتقول إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية (FAA) إن الطائرات كانت
مفصولة فقط  ألف قدم ، دعونا
نناقش مع
المفتش العام السابق بوزارة النقل ماري
شيافو ، واو ماري ، ما هو أولاً وقبل كل شيء
ما هو رد فعلك على هذا
حسنًا ، ليس رد فعلي ، ما
حدث هنا يقع في
أخطر فئة من غزوات
المدرج إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية FAA
يقسمهم من خلال جدية
المعونة ب ج ود وهذا هو الجزء العلوي هذا
هو الأكثر  هناك ما يقرب
من 20 من هذه الفئات الأكثر خطورة من A و B
كل عام ، ولكن الإحصائيات الأكثر إثارة للقلق
هي أن غارات المدرج
بعبارة أخرى طائرتان على مدرج أو
ضرائب عندما لا يُفترض أن
تتقاطعان تكون معرضة لخطر
تقاطعها  هو أن ذلك قد ارتفع بنسبة 92 في المائة من عام
2011 حتى عام 2018. لذا فهذه مشكلة كبيرة
مع الحكومة مع إدارة الطيران الفيدرالية
ومع مكتبي القديم مكتب
المفتش العام لأن هذه
إحصائية واحدة آخذة في الارتفاع
وليست إحصائية تريدها  لنرى الارتفاع